and a few hours ago I had the
opportunity to sit down with the
president here's part one we'll show you
the entire interview part one of my
interview with President Trump right
after this historic meeting historic day
well it's just I think most people like
me want to know what was going on in
that room one-on-one well the big thing
is this is now my 25th hour of being up
and negotiating and we've been
negotiating very hard this is about the
complete verifiable irreversible
denuclearization of the entire Peninsula
so without that we could not have had a
deal I mean but one thing upfront we
want to de nuke the entire Peninsula we
want to de nuke that whole situation
that is a hotbed and you know what's
been happening for years and nobody did
anything about it and you have to we
have no choice we had to the
relationship was really good the you
know it built and I talked about early
on in the relationship and the feeling
well we had a very good feel right from
the beginning and we were able to get
something very important done and
actually some things happened after that
was signed Sean where we're getting rid
of certain missile research areas
certain missile testing sites they're
getting rid of a lot you know in the
lead up to this and this was pretty
amazing because obviously I'm a pretty
strong critic of our news media in that
country but a lot it happened he
dismantled a nuclear test site he
crossed over the DMZ three hostages were
released the missiles stopped being
fired he was Willy he you wouldn't have
come here if he did not if he was not
willing to talk about denuclearization
that's right
so all of that happened before you
walked in and I don't remember that you
sent cargo planes a cache or gave
anything really
before the lead-up why do you know why
do you think he's interested in doing
this after spending that time with sort
of interesting because I noticed some of
the precedent I'm not even knocking him
because honestly that the treating we
very good on the subject what's the
treat badly but some of the press would
say he's meeting with them and therefore
he has a
major loss I said since when and you
know others wanted to it never worked
out it probably never could have worked
out but we really have gotten a lot you
haven't seen missiles going up in seven
or eight months you haven't seen
research you haven't seen nuclear tests
very importantly Japan is very happy
because they were being encircled I mean
there was a period of time when they
were going right over the middle of
Japan and we got our hostages back and
you're right we didn't pay for that but
but I think I don't say that in a
braggadocious way at all because he did
such a smart thing because that was such
a good a good thing to do and and I feel
so badly about otto warmbier that was
the one thing and Otto did not die in
vain I actually believed and I've gotten
very friendly without as parents they're
incredible people devastated as they you
know as you would think great parents he
was a great young man but I think
without Otto this whole thing wouldn't
have happened because it crystallized
when he came back in the condition it
crystallized so much to so many people
maybe even to the other side frankly but
I think that Otto truly did not die in
vain I've known you for a lot of years
and I think one trait that I could say
is brutal honesty in the room alone and
then the subsequent talks with your team
or in their team how honest how brutal
what was said bring it try and bring
people into the room so we got along
very well we get along from the
beginning we started off he and myself
and two interpreters and from the
beginning we got along you know I've
made the statement and I've said it
before I've said it about a lot of
different kinds of relationships you can
almost tell right at the beginning
did you tell at the beginning what was
your what was that my first minute no I
felt very good at the beginning and we
you know I talked about we have to
denote this country has to be deduct and
he understood that he fully understood
it he didn't fight it and we're doing
some great things and for his country
and South Korea's going to be involved
very much in helping and Japan is going
to be involved and President Xi of China
has been
you know really terrific on the border I
think let's say the last couple of
months unfortunately not a big part but
this is your meetings when you've met
with the president of China was
scheduled if I were call for like 15
minutes didn't someone go on for four
hours but we actually met at mar-a-lago
he wanted to be at mar-a-lago and we had
a 15 minute meeting scheduled when he
comes then we were going to go into
breakout rooms where we had many people
waiting for us and it ended up lasting
for hours the 15 minutes president of
China great guy it ended up lasting for
four hours we just got along and we have
got no long I mean I wanted to treat us
better and trade that's my only problem
you know they make concessions on the
electoral property they want to do
things it's a tough thing you know they
doing so well they've made so much
progress against us for so many years
it's awfully tough for them to bring it
back and we'll see how that all works
out we're gonna we're gonna do something
definitely we're gonna do something you
know they offered us eighty billion
dollars in purchases of agricultural
products but it's just not enough for
what we're talking about eighty billion
what do you want to throw I turned down
eighty billion dollars but we have to do
something with intellectual property we
have to do something just generally on
trade last year we lost five hundred
billion dollars with China we can't do
that anymore I
[Music]